do you think there's like a difference
between traditional celebrities and
internet celebrities because yes I think
because obviously we've been in a
position obviously we've been in a
position
yeah yeah obviously we've been in a
position where we've been trying to you
know convince a lot of conventions to be
like look
internet's you know people with internet
followings you have to like take them
more seriously yeah but at the same time
do you think that they should be treated
on the same level and what just
conventions I think I think it depends
on the size of I'm also biased as [ __ ]
yeah like it's treat me normal yeah no
that's the thing I think I think a lot
of like internet celebrities or I guess
like the the common understanding of how
internet celebrity should be is that oh
because we see them on the Internet
because a lot of them are you know kind
of uh like self-produced and all that
kind of stuff it's like oh they're just
like one of us you know they're a lot
more grounded whereas like the common
understanding of like movie celebrities
or TV celebrities or musicians is that
like oh they're these people on top of
the clouds that I'll never be close to
touching which has been put on a
pedestal they've been put on so high of
a pedal still that unless I am at their
level I will never ever ever interact
with them yeah whereas like YouTubers or
twitch streamers and you know a lot of
other people who have like a social
media presence it's like oh well I enter
interact with them on Twitter yeah you
know indirectly but that's still better
than what any chance I'll get with
[ __ ] you know Samuel Jackson or
Robert Downey Jr yeah right so I think
it's but
at the same time I think nowadays as as
you were saying it's kind of getting to
the point now where the line's getting a
bit blurry because it's like after what
point does it go from just being this
another guy on the internet so then
suddenly you know being something like
Mr Beast or Felix where it's like now
they are sometimes even more famous than
the traditional celebrities yeah I don't
because I don't know what that line is
or how to define it but like I think
there is a definite difference
um I guess I realize this have we I
don't think we've talked about our
VidCon experience have we or your guys a
VidCon oh our guys is a VidCon
experience or just the one party that we
went to yeah where it was just you go to
this VidCon party
I mean kind of went to this vidcon's
party so we didn't actually attend
VidCon we went to one of the video
I have enough clout and I was just I was
I felt so dirty
that's why do you think I didn't go it's
okay so I I didn't want to go it was
also like an hour away we had it like
Yeah because it was like near [ __ ]
Disneyland and we were staying in like
other Hollywood Hills yeah
so so so this was like the most [ __ ]
it was basically like an in-betweeners
episode for us right because we get in
and we're like okay so there's this
VidCon party um and we just like I
wanted to hang out with like Emily
indictis and everything like that
mail-in tags along as well so she's like
I think I think I think I can get us in
I think I think I got some contacts in
there turns out uh she did not that's it
the one time mailing didn't have a
contact turns out the one time melon
didn't have a contact they were out of
office or not working that day so we
couldn't get in so we had to kind of
like try and let's say sneak our way
into the video like we said this at one
point where we mentioned I think on that
there's nothing we had I think we have
no we have swear we didn't we have I
don't think we've talked about apologies
we've
definitely said it in private but uh
yeah I think uh
so the how we get in is Emily and didus
um and a bunch of other creators uh that
we knew were in the party uh they had
they had passes and basically you needed
a pass to get in if I remember correctly
and so what what we try to do was get
didus to sneak some to sneak some passes
out by himself a Junior's plan go in
with the passes there's no checks to
leave yeah just leave with the passes in
your pants the extra ones then come give
us the passes and we'll come back in yes
I did hear about that is showing passes
down his parents he was like I'm scared
they're gonna Pat me down like why would
they pat you down to leave yeah what do
you mean that's not how it works he's
like oh I'm freaking out I'm like no no
they don't pat you down when you get out
of it you'll be fine you'll be fine yeah
you'll be fine so already there's me
Connor and May Lin waiting outside the
uh outside the venue and I'm just like
why am I doing this like in in my head
I'm like why am I doing this this party
is not going to be worth it I already
feel dirty being here why am I doing
this and then while we're waiting we
heard like the most VidCon conversation
you could possibly hear this was
literally like this summed up VidCon
yeah I'm excited now yeah so these two
guys walked past and one of the guys
goes uh so yeah last year I was just
like pretending to be relevant this year
is like the first year I actually feel
like I am relevant and I that was like
the one line where I'm like I need to
leave
right now because this dude walked past
I mean God looked at each other and
we're like all right
it was funny I kept seeing that guy in
the party because I remember who it was
right I saw him in the party literally
trying to talk to every big YouTuber oh
my trying his [ __ ] hardest to talk to
everyone
yeah yeah he was just like well he was
relevant you know this is the first year
he was relevant oh [ __ ] if he says he's
relevant I guess he is but it's like
half people in that party won't even
create I'm like
yeah it's so easy to do it yeah yeah and
like you go in and you just like we
didn't recognize anyone because everyone
it's like VidCon now was like a
Tick-Tock party yeah you know
because God damn they're relevant I saw
some YouTubers I knew they were my
friends are like hey hi hi hi how you
doing do you know anyone here no no I
don't know anyone either who are these
people definitely felt like the Boomers
in the party and I remember I remember
like I guess like the the one big
YouTuber I got like a glance at I guess
who did kind of give off celebrity Vibes
by The Way They Carried themselves was
we were waiting in line
Bill's after dinos came out and gave us
the passes we were waiting in line to
get it through security and then someone
just rocks up and you see an entire
Posse just like rocking up and I see
this guy and you know you know when like
you know when you see someone walking
and they just give off kind of like
[ __ ] energy yeah so I'm like oh damn
there's like a certain strike yeah this
is a stride
I see you uh I see one person like run
up to this person and like because like
and she goes oh can I can I please take
a picture can I please take a picture
and uh he turns around and it's James
and it's James Charles and he just goes
no and just drops off and that that was
uh that was my one holy [ __ ] what an
alpha that is that I swear you've told
the story in the podcast oh I'm going
crazy we'll find out
don't tell me I don't think I have
taught the story yeah I mean it was it
was what you think it is yeah it was
like a big nightclub yeah kind of like
every nightclub and every uh action
movie yeah you're like yeah you can't
see anything it's just a bunch of people
who are dressed really funnily like
obviously there's a lot of tick tock
creators who have like a stick and
there's other people like dressed
weirdly yeah I'm like what though
and so I should talk to YouTubers that I
know and yeah I'm bumped into William
Now sort of William a lot William Osmond
yeah I was like do you know anyone here
he's like no he's like and I was like is
it was it always like this he was like
no no like when VidCon started you knew
everyone yeah because they were all
YouTubers now he's like that's all tick
tock I don't know anyone here I I kind
of felt the same way when I went to the
otk party as well oh really because it's
like yeah because like otk is like a
twitch uh group or like uh Team I guess
yeah um like we have we all have a
couple of friends who are because you
just didn't watch a lot of twitch she
didn't recognize any of them no it
wasn't even that it was like because I
went with Ross uh Robert Ross
um and you know he's a lot more like in
tune with like the twist streamers and
stuff like that and so we we rock up and
for one there's barely anyone there yeah
like maybe like other than like Tech and
see it and like a couple of other people
and like Rich no no other otk member was
there oh okay and I was just looking
around and I was like I don't mean to be
a boomer but like I don't know anyone
like I literally can't recognize any
anyone here and Ross was like yeah I
kind of don't recognize anyone here
either well because twitch streamers
come up really fast yeah exactly so yeah
so I was just like you know I mean we
went and we like hung out and like the
entire night I was just talking to Tech
and Ross no I didn't go there to
socialize at all I just went for the
free tricks
but like yeah I feel like it was kind of
the same way we're like oh I realized
then and there that I don't like these
kinds of parties just because you don't
parties you literally don't get anything
out of it it is it is the biggest
[ __ ] waste of time yeah it depends on
the person I think sometimes I like them
sometimes I don't if you've got a couple
of friends there then you can just hang
out with them it depends
everyone yeah having a good time other
times you're like God I really regret
coming here yeah yeah exactly and I
think it's because of that that I heard
VidCon funny I was like no I just
thought I'd never been to a VidCon party
and I wanted to see like the vultures I
just wanted to see oh you definitely saw
them and I I got to I hey I knew it
would be like a human experiment ground
of clout like I just knew it would be
funny to go and just watch people try
and to be fair it was yeah like you
would just see like a big a really big
YouTubers well known in the corner and
then people just constantly trying to
get in the conversation he definitely
like weren't being subtle about it and
it was so funny it was cool it was
almost like watching a nature
ready to pounce at the opportunity to
make a connection unfortunately for him
this prey is not biting it looks like
there's an opening oh but no there's a
rejection there's been an awkward
silence it's not happening oh my God I
need to see that and you could see the
herb of the herd of tick tock is
surrounded this lone YouTuber
who is now an endangered species
it was just like yeah it was it was so
weird because it was one of the weirdest
parties I've been to because I've had
every VidCon party's like that which
didn't get her enough
I hope that every single one of the
parties was rammed and then when we went
to like the Denny's afterwards I kept
overhearing conversations from other
Tick Tock creators talking about like
they like to like you're doing like the
exact conversation someone was like are
you you guys doing taxes and they were
all like baffled they were all like uh
I'm not doing are you doing taxes
I was like eating my [ __ ] meal like
casual tax brought in the Denny's but it
wasn't like a it wasn't like a you're
evading it right it was like yeah yeah
we should are we supposed is this
something we're supposed to are we
supposed to be because they were all
like 21 I think like Brands yeah yeah
exactly first thing they done they
didn't it was just funny it was really
good yeah it was really oh you naive
child it was just like it was like you
bring in a bunch of these creators who
have popped up and never been to uh
because you know the interesting thing
about going to VidCon this year was that
this is the first VidCon since a
pandemic right yes yes so a lot of the
people who when this is their first time
ever going to an event with other
influencers or YouTubers or anything
like that yeah so it was just like
probably it was like a wild it was just
so fun to watch because it was literally
like you could tell a lot of people had
no idea how to introduce or kind of you
know kind of talk people yeah you just
watch people do oh my God man there's
like one or two dudes who are like doing
an awful job of trying out because I was
interested we were in the outside
section the whole time there's a little
outside section there's just one like a
bunch of people just kept trying to go
and talk to Big YouTubers and just
having miserable luck did anyone come up
to you guys or no we were like tucked
away in the corner I had a few people
who came up to me and were like oh I I
watched trash days are like oh I don't
know who you are because that was the
awkward part some of them would
introduce themselves and be like I'm
blah blah blah yeah they would be like
I'm this person kind of like not really
elaborate and I was like oh is that like
because
I want to be like I don't know yeah
because it's awkward if you're like I
don't know who you are just like oh
we're using our fake names uh we're
using our real names well because they
would be like oh you're thinking yeah oh
I know thingy thingy yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think I prefer that though
to be honest
like you wanna you don't want to be the
biggest one there because you you get
swarmed yeah exactly and I I think like
someone said a story about like Mr Beast
going the day before yeah William was
talking about Mr Beast guy oh my God I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have wanted to
like go to be the party in that case and
apparently everyone was just like you
know how like l in Death Note it's like
that was what it was like right everyone
was doing it and it was just like [ __ ]
why even bother going far out I wouldn't
go yeah it's just like damn imagine
being Jimmy you get sworn by fans and
even going to like creative parties you
get sworn by creators as well right yeah
yeah every every YouTuber out there's
like this is how my fans should act and
then it goes out the window and they're
the ones doing it